une ruche de ruches le palais d'hiver et
celui des congrès bourdonnais hier de
centaines de coiffeurs des modèles
brigands les pics promise en compétition
par le comité artistique de la coiffure
française
coiffure messieurs tout d'abord palais
d'hiver tendance à sagy vous pouvez vous
en rendre compte sculpter ou floues et
les moins excentrique mais c'est un bon
point
pour les dames de belles choses
également mais une constatation s'impose
avant que nous retenons notre souffle
pour ne pas faire crouler ces savants
j'ai des échafaudages la mode de bonnut
n'a pas inspiré but to know figaro
la coiffure c'est bien mais il ne faut
pas non plus oublier le visage ni les
ondes un concours annexes était donc
organisé esthétique et manucure
au total plus de vingt lauréats
récompensés au cours de la nuit de la
toiture organisée à l'issue des épreuves